deux mots et blanchâtres identique aux
milliers d'autres et pourtant c'est vous
la future reine des fourmis ainsi que
votre frère un des princes comme on
l'avait vu sur notre vidéo comment
devenir la reine des abeilles certaines
larves dans la ruche sont sélectionnés
au hasard par les ouvrières pour être
nourri à la gelée royale ce qui les
transformera en reine pendant longtemps
on a pensé que c'était pareil chez les
fourmis on ne comprenait pas la
mécanique de sélection en fait
contrairement aux abeilles c'est votre
mère la reine qui vous a volontairement
choisie elle a pondu des oeufs spéciaux
vous concrètement ça se passe comment en
fait la reine dans son ventre a trois
options d'abord faire une ouvrière pour
ça le fait qu'on qu une ville avec un
spermatozoïde
comme les humains elle le pioche dans sa
spermathèque un organe où elle stocke un
maximum de sperme pendant la
reproduction comme chez les abeilles
elle peut aussi faire une soldats avec
la tête plus grosse c'est le même
principe que l'ouvrière mais ses soeurs
vont choisir de sécréter des phéromones
spéciale sur environ 5% des larves
deuxième option la reine peut faire des
princes pour ça elle va uniquement
pondre des oeufs non fécondé sans
spermatozoïdes enfin elle peut faire des
futures reines pour ça elle va se
reproduire tout seul il la reine arrive
à fusionner les noyaux de deux de ses
propres ovules pour former un oeuf de
princesse celle-ci ne s'occupera pas de
ses enfants fraîchement pondus ce sont
vos quand soeurs ouvrières qui vont vous
nourrir vous lécher et vous retourner
régulièrement certaines espèces ou
badigeonne même d'acide formique et d'un
poison mortel pour vous protéger des
bactéries moisissures beaucoup d'espèces
choisissent alors de se construire un
solide cocons de soie voyez la
différence avec les biens protégés vous
allez pouvoir passer de 9 à l'art de la
rv à 9 vaut pas douze antennes et le
reste de vos organes commence à se
construire à l'intérieur les antennes
les fourmis sont hyper importante elles
sont composées de milliers de petits
poils qu'on appelle les sens il elles
permettent de toucher de goûter de
sentir et même de détecter les
phéromones ce développement est très
coûteux en énergie chaque jour vous
aurez besoin de consommer un tiers de
votre peau en nourriture une fourmilière
consume plus de 2 kg de nourriture par
jour une fois devenu neuf vos organes et
vos membrane sont maintenant bien
visible vous êtes prêtes à éclore les
futures reines sont de grosses fourni au
thorax et abdomen bien développée pour y
accueillir la spermathèque et les ailes
les principes eux sont de taille
intermédiaire avec un thorax bien
développée pour y accueillir aussi des
ailes la tête par contre est bien plus
petit que les mandibules et le muscle
aussi vu qu'ils en auront pas besoin
tout comme leur cerveau moins développé
que les ouvrières qui ont des
interactions et des comportements
sociaux plus complexe ouais le mâle
fourmis sert un peu à rien ce jeune
fourmis royal sont de gros bébés prince
comme princess auront la vie de château
gavé par leurs ouvrières afin
d'accumuler des réserves nutritionnelle
sous forme de liquide tout ça en
attendant le grand jour le vol nuptial
lors d'une belle et chaude journée d'été
sans vendre avant ou après un orage les
ouvrières de différents ni sont dans un
état d'excitation extrême elle sort en
masse du nid agrandissant les sorties
pour vous la vie de château est
désormais terminé un mur un arbre de
l'herbe qu'importe sera fréquent que
vous chantiez plusieurs fois avant de
décoller comme vous êtes resté dans le
nid pendant des semaines sans utiliser
vos ailes vous n'êtes pas encore bien
habitués certaines des princesses
n'auront même pas l'occasion de décoller
à cause de malformations comme des ailes
tordu plier ou atrophiée les condamnant
à la mort vous sentez désormais une
odeur attirante des phéromones de
princes et de princesses d'autres nids
qui veulent se reproduire avec vous mais
soudain des prédateurs des oiseaux vous
attaque c'est un carnage votre vol lent
et maladroit fait de vous une prof
facile et des centaines mort en quelques
minutes vous vous avez de la chance non
seulement vous avez survécu mais vous
trouver un partenaire de reproduction le
plus souvent les trains sera unique et
se fera à deux mais chez quelques
espèces
les princesses utilise plusieurs mâles
elles récupèrent leurs fluides stockées
dans votre spermathèque qui vous
permettra de donner naissance à des
millions de pour l'instant dehors vous
êtes en danger permanent il vous faut
chercher une fissure dans le sol pour
vous cacher des prédateurs vauzelle
devienne un handicap alors vous devez
vous les arracher ce qui vous laissera
des cicatrices durant toute votre vie
darren c'est le rite de passage à trop
ce que doivent s'infliger toutes les
princesses qui veulent devenir mère et
votre calvaire ne s'arrête pas là car au
sol de nouveaux prédateurs encore plus
mortels vous attendent et les arts les
araignées les mantes religieuses sans
oublier les ouvrières des colonies
voisines affamés car oui des fourmis
ennemis qui sortiront massivement de
leurs nids attirés par les phéromones
face à tout ça les oiseaux dans le ciel
s'était presque rassurant et les princes
dans tout ça après l'accouplement comme
pour les abeilles ils vont connaître un
triste sort ce qui peut leur arriver de
mieux c'est mourir de faim la plupart du
temps ils seront juste très peu c'est
par d'autres fourmis aux prédateurs
parce que s'ils décident de retourner au
nid familial aux soeurs ouvrières
n'accepterait pas son retour à quoi
servirait ce gros lourdaud à part
gaspiller des ressources sera déchiqueté
par sa propre famille il ne reste donc
plus que vous la reine est une question
comment fonder une nouvelle colonie
trois scénarios s'offrent à vous en
fonction de votre espèce d'abord créé un
nouveau nid tout seul vous allez devoir
attendre de pondre au premier ouvrière
pour pouvoir être nourri correctement
une petite dizaine au départ faut
commencer petit en attendant vous vivez
sur vos réserves ou digérer même vos
propres muscles notamment ceux de vaud l
arraché après quoi vos filles vous
aideront à creuser et construire votre
royaume deuxième solution plus simple
retournez à votre nid de naissance vous
pourrez y re vivre paisiblement avec vos
soeurs et votre vieille mère ou bien
leur faire la guerre il ya des reines
conquérante comme ça qu'ils reviennent
décimé l'endroit qui les a nourris soit
vous êtes polly jean soit vous êtes
oligo gym dans les deux cas les
ouvrières sont entièrement dévoués à
toutes les rênes même quand elle se bat
il suffit de les manipuler grâce à ces
phéromones pour éviter ça chaque rennes
est gardé dans un secteur précis il faut
absolument éviter qu'elles se baladent
et rencontre une de ses concurrentes
normalement il ya de la place beaucoup
de place les fourmilières sont de
véritables villes souterraines on y
retrouve des meneurs se rit des greniers
à nourrir la salle royale ou des salles
d'hibernation et ça peut être énorme des
chercheurs ont coulé 10 tonnes de ciment
dans le nid de fourmis brésilienne et
regarder l'étendue presque 2000 chambres
de la taille d'un ballon de foot
certaines espèces sont des supers
colonies pouvant s'étendre sur des
centaines de kilomètres par exemple les
fourmis argentine ont créé un empire qui
s'étend des côtes méditerranéennes du
portugal à l'italie 6000km
interconnectés à l'opposé les plus
petites colonies de fourmis peuvent être
contenues dans une simple noisette il ya
des nids de terre de brady de
champignons qu'elle cultive avec des
feuilles
des toiles de soi qui leur permettent de
coller des feuilles entre elles dans des
branches oui deignan d'altitude vous
cogner une branche et là des milliers de
fourmis vous explose au visage plus
cauchemardesque un nid de guêpes comme
dernier exemple quoi de mieux qu'une
fourmilière dont les murs sont faits par
vos propres enfants oui les fourmis
légionnaires tropicale s'accroche entre
elles pour créer une structure
protégeant la reine et les yeux comme un
immeuble construit d'humains piles et
les fourmis sont terrifiantes et
pourtant un jour viendra quand la reine
des fourmis mort à 28 ans ont passé
depuis votre naissance chaque jour vous
avez pondu entre 100 et 2000 ce à
l'échelle de votre vie c'est une dizaine
de millions de fourmi auquel vous avez
donné naissance vous n'avez fait que ça
vous n'êtes sortie unique une fois pour
la reproduction puis plus jamais vous
n'avez vu la lumière du soleil grâce à
votre sacrifice vous pouvez être fiers
vous avez construit quelque chose de
grand c'était long mais maintenant vous
vous sentez faiblir une fois votre
spermathèque vide vous ne pouvez plus
pondre d'ouvrières pour s'occuper de
vous et de votre colonie dans le cas où
vous êtes la seule reine la fin de la
ponte signifie un long déclin de la
colonie une ouvrière n'ayant une durée
de vie que de deux ans bientôt votre
site et sera vidé s'écroulant sur elle
même car même les plus belles oeuvres
des pyramides à nos gratte ciel ne sont
pas éternels par contre il y à d'autres
reines dans la colonie dont vos propres
filles maintenant mère y aura pas de
retraite au soleil les ouvrières
n'hésiteront pas à vous tuer pour vous
donner comme nourriture au lard de vos
filles et de vos soeurs chez les fourmis
on gaspille pas les protéines après une
vie de labeur vous voilà déchiqueté par
vos filles dont vous vous êtes si peu
occupé au final vous avez construit un
empire creuser des structures
monumentales éradiquer tous vos
concurrents et conquis la forêt entière
tout ça avec votre seul ventre fécond
mais memento mori
c'est ce qu'on disait au général romain
victor ue qui paradaient en ville tu as
gagné tu te sens fort mais n'oubliez pas
la mort peut-être fallait-il y penser
plus tôt adieu reine des fourmis
[Musique]